president Trump's personal lawyer
Michael Khan pleads guilty and there's a
lot and is about at a CNN commentator
calls for the elimination of the udin
from the Middle East and a new study
suggests that white leftists pandered
minorities who would have thought it i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the news cycle simply does not slow and
we will get to all of it in just one
second but first let's talk about what
you need to do if you actually want to
sell your house so you know a couple of
years ago I had to sell my house I
wanted to sell my house and I was
looking for a great real estate agent
and it was very difficult I'd go through
several real estate agents before we
found the right one who was able to sell
our home at the right price in the right
amount of time
you shouldn't have to struggle through
that you should have the best real
estate agent available to you anytime
and this is why you need home like calm
it's the innovative solution that makes
it easy to find the best real estate
agent for you why do you need a top real
estate agent because on average top
agents sell homes 8 days faster and 9%
above asking price which could mean
thousands of dollars back in your pocket
having a great real estate agent makes a
huge difference I know I've had bad ones
and I've had good ones home light is
100% free unbiased and it takes less
than two minutes unlike some other real
estate agent sites agents actually can't
pay to advertise on home light instead
home light uses data from over 38
million home sales and two million
agents to recommend the top real estate
agents home light brings trust and
transparency to the real estate space so
you can buy or sell with confidence
knowing that you're working with the
best real estate agent for your needs
they've introduced over 200 47,000
buyers and sellers to top local real
estate agents so if you're planning to
sell your home now is the time to find
the best real estate agent all you have
to do right now to get started is go to
home light calm Shapiro today that's
home light calm / apparel gets started
you can earn up to five hundred dollars
when you buy or sell your home using a
home light referred real estate agent
again that's hom e li ght calm home-like
calm / Shapiro for up to five hundred
bucks when you find the best real estate
agent and buy or sell your home with
hope with home I totally worth it really
I mean this an important thing terms and
conditions to apply go check it out home
lake comm / appear oh okay so the big
breaking news Michael Cohen the
president's personal lawyer not a smart
cookie as the president might say he has
now pled guilty in a new deal with
Robert Muller now this is kind of a
shock because people thought that
Michael Cohen the president's personal
lawyer was going to plead guilty in a
deal with the Southern District of New
York the DA of the Southern District of
New York that's because the original
investigation around Michael Cohen that
everybody was worried about was the
investigation concerning the supposed
bribery of stormy Daniels the the
original
story if you recall was that President
Trump had allegedly used Michael Cohen
as a thoroughfare for paying off his
former lover stormy Daniels and had done
so specifically in order to avoid
campaign finance law that was the
allegation in any case that's why the
Southern District of New York was
investigating because it had nothing to
do with election 2016 and the Trump
Russia election stuff it has to do with
campaign finance reform it headed with
the election but not with any of the
Trump Russia stuff that is actually
under Robert Muller's purview well now
it turns out that Michael Cohen has pled
guilty in a deal with Robert Muller so
why exactly is he pleading guilty in a
deal with Robert Muller well here's
where things begin to get quite dicey
for the Trump campaign / administration
here is the ABC news report special
counsel Robert Muller has reached a
tentative deal with Michael Kohn the
former personal attorney and longtime
fixer for President Donald Trump sources
told ABC News Cohn appeared in federal
court in Manhattan Thursday where he
entered a guilty plea for Miss
statements to Congress in closed-door
testimony last year about his contacts
during the presidential campaign on the
AP reported that it was a surprise
appearance which is sort of a weird
statement
it's like Barbra Streisand showing up
randomly at the Hollywood Bowl except
that it was Michael Cohen showing up in
courts plead guilty first of all it is a
very rare occurrence when somebody
pleads guilty for Mis statements to
Congress that's very rare what it
suggests is that Muller thinks that he
had more hanging over Kahn's head Cohen
pled guilty to a lesser charge and then
gave all sorts of material to the Muller
investigation so what exactly is the
Muller investigation getting in return
for allowing Michael Cohen to take a
light guilty plea well here's what ABC
News reports Cohen's earlier plea deal
federal prosecutors in the Southern
District of New York implicated
President Trump and campaign finance
felonies
since then Cohn has spent more than 70
hours in interviews monters team never
good thing the questioning has focused
on contacts with Russians by Trump
associates during the campaign Trump's
business ties to Russia obstruction of
justice and talk of possible pardons
sources familiar with the discussions
have told ABC News Kendall coffee of
former US attorney in Florida says the
potential significance of Cohen's
cooperation is immense so what exactly
is Cohen telling the Muller
investigation that is not eminently
clear at this point but the suggestion
is that Cohen lied to Congress about
president Trump's continuing connections
with Russian companies in the middle of
the 2016 election sources familiar with
the special counsels proposed agreement
with Cohen told ABC News the 52 year old
New Yorker will admit to making multiple
missed statements to to congressional
intelligence committees investigating
alleged collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia to influence the
2016 presidential election it was not
immediately clear what Cohen told the
congressional committees in the fall of
2017 that he will now say was false the
other reports are already speculating
that it's that Cohen had said that Trump
was not involved in negotiations over
the building of a Trump Tower in Moscow
into mid 2016 and now it turns out that
Trump was directly involved in exactly
those sorts of conversations Cohen
played an integral role according to ABC
News in discussions about a possible
Trump Tower in Moscow negotiations that
were going on at least through the early
stages of the 2016 presidential campaign
so here's where we get a problem okay
the the the reason that this is a
problem is because if it turns out that
the President of the United States
during the 2016 campaign was involved in
business transactions with the Russian
government and the Russian government
was basically rooting for Trump to win
because they thought that they had him
bought and thus they were helping him
out in the election this is another
Avenue of Investigation for Muller Cohen
clay according to the steel dossier it
asserted that Cohen had a key role in
secretive Trump campaign connections
with Kremlin operatives Cohen claimed in
a statement that the proposal he worked
on during the campaign to build a Trump
property and Moscow quote was solely a
real-estate deal and nothing more Cohen
said the plan was terminated in January
2016 after it was determined that the
project was not viable for business
reasons now apparently he is saying
something different now he is saying
that the deal continued all the way into
June 2016 this is according to Reuters
president Trump has responded he denied
working on a Trump Organization real
estate project in Moscow which Cohen
said they pursued until June 2016 during
the presidential campaign Trump attacked
his former lawyer he called him a weak
person an accused Cohen of lying about
the real estate project to try and
obtain a reduced sentence from
prosecutors from told reporters outside
the White House he had decided not to
build the building in Moscow although he
did not specify when he decided against
pursuing that project now again the
reason this is important is because if
Trump was actually in the
business negotiations with a
geopolitical enemy of the United States
in the middle of a presidential run in
which there are accusations that
geopolitical enemy was rooting for Trump
and trying to hack his political
opponents in order to release material
to get an ally elected that is a problem
even if that were true would that mean
that there is active collusion between
Trump and the Russians no actually right
let's say that President Trump or in the
middle of a business relationship with
the Russian government to build a Trump
Tower in Moscow would that look bad sure
they look really bad would it look about
as bad as Hillary Clinton using the
State Department to reach out to various
and sundry governments who were giving
donations to the Clinton Foundation it
would look kind of like that would it
mean that President Trump was selling
influence no because he wasn't president
yet would it mean that he was colluding
with the Russians to release Hillary
Clinton's emails no that would have to
be proven independently however it would
create an incentive for the Russian
government to want Trump to win and this
has been a hot point of contention in
the Muller investigation all along is
that the Russians really wanted Trump to
win or is it that they just wanted to
cause electoral chaos there's been a
split in the intelligence community over
which it is did they actually want Trump
to become president so they were rooting
against Hillary and trying to undermine
Hillary or were they undermining Hillary
just to create chaos
assuming that Hillary Clinton was going
to win anyway so all of this is is
obviously dicey for president Trump and
it comes amidst a bunch of other dicey
material with regard to President Trump
and that other material includes the
mulher office now looking at phone calls
between President Trump and the and
Roger stone a long time
president Trump confidants as we
mentioned yesterday there is all this
material that was coming out with regard
to Roger stone the suggestion that Roger
stone had been coordinating with
WikiLeaks in the dump of material on
Hillary Clinton and that they had been
sort of a go-between for President Trump
and WikiLeaks Mona's office is now
apparently looking at late-night phone
calls between Roger stone and President
Trump according to the Washington Post
this broke late yesterday the calls
almost always came deep into the night
caller ID labeled them unknown barrage
of stone said he knew to pick up quickly
during those harried months of the 2016
presidential campaign there'd be a good
chance the voice on the other end of the
line would belong to President Donald
Trump then just Donald Trump dialing
from a blocked phone number
those nocturnal chats and other contacts
between the man
who now occupies the Oval Office and an
infamous political trickster have come
under intensifying scrutiny as Special
Counsel Robert Muller's investigation
bores into whether stone served as a
bridge between Trump and WikiLeaks as
the group was publishing hacked emails
Roger stone of course denies that
President Trump and he ever talked
WikiLeaks who the hell knows whether
that is true or not Roger stone is a
congenital liar and president Trump is
not exactly forthcoming on these matters
here's Roger stone telling Sean Hannity
no no we never talked about any of that
sort of WikiLeaks stuff did you ever
talk to the president about Julian
Assange or WikiLeaks ever absolutely not
and so the president called the Trulie
what we learned today yes absolutely we
had no time did Donald Trump and I
either candidate Trump or president
Trump discuss WikiLeaks meanwhile jerome
corsi another supposed to go between
between wikileaks and actually Roger
stone jerome corsi rejected a plea
agreement this week suggesting that he
was not going to be forced to lie by the
Muller team he says listen I'm not
taking a deal and I could go to jail
because I'm not gonna allow team Muller
to force me to lie in order to go after
president Trump you were offered a plea
deal by Bob Miller's team that's correct
why did you reject it well I felt the
deal was fraudulent it required me to
lie and it required me to violate
various regulations and even I thought
commit fraud and I won't do that I will
not lie to keep myself out of jail and I
realized that I could go to jail for the
rest of my life I'm 72 years old I might
die in jail but I'm still making this
decision okay so one of the
possibilities here is that it's not that
he's actually innocent in all this stuff
it's that he's angling for a
presidential pardon
like Paul Manafort but Michael Cohen
obviously has despaired of a
presidential pardon and is now working
with the Muller investigation forth with
stone and Corsi both have defense
arrangements with President Trump's team
this leads to a point that we're talking
about yesterday with regard to the
possibility of president from pardoning
Paul Manafort
or pardoning Roger stone or pardoning
jerome corsi the president could
theoretically cut off all ends of an
investigation
simply by pardoning all the people who
are under investigation ken white known
as Pope had on Twitter he's a criminal
defense lawyer former federal prosecutor
he has an article
the New York Times specifically talking
about Paul Manafort
and why Paul Manafort has a defense
agreement and why exactly the Muller
team is now deciding to revoke his plea
arrangement in favor of prosecuting him
more strongly here's what Ken White says
he says on Tuesday the Times reported
that mr. Matt affords lawyers have been
telling mr. Trump's lawyers what the
special counsel are special counsel
asked Mr Man afford and what the latter
said in response the first development
isn't much of a surprise this is the
development that suggests that Miller
filed a status report accusing Manta
Ford of lying why as prosecutors know
cooperating witnesses can be notoriously
unreliable it's not unusual for
prosecutors to catch co-operators in
lies or recidivism but the second
development that mr. manna forts lawyers
have been spilling the details of their
clients cooperation to trump lawyers
under the cover of an often-used but
little understood pacts called the joint
defense agreement is shocking the
revelation is a potential catastrophe
for everyone involved in a second I'm
going to get into Ken White's analysis
of what exactly it means that Paul
Manafort now has a joint defense
agreement with President Trump and
apparently it looks like the same thing
may soon exist with Jerome Corsi or
Roger stone what all this means for
president Trump and impeachment we'll
get to in just a second first let's talk
about how you defend your rights in
reality is that the founding fathers
believed deeply in 2nd amendment why
because they knew that the only thing
standing between tyranny and the
American people is the American people's
right to defend themselves Bravo Company
manufacturing knows that too they were
started in the garage by a Marine
veteran more than 2 decades ago to build
a professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer
manufacturer life-saving equipment they
assume that each rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier oversees
every component of a BCM rifle is hand
assemble tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard Lycia Morris with
leading instructors of marksmanship from
top levels from America's Special
Operations Forces from Marine Corps
force reconnaissance to US Army Special
Ops forces who can teach the skills
necessary to defend yourself your family
or others they have all sorts of great
services plus they produce great
products to learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm where you can
discover more about their products
special offers and upcoming
newse that's Bravo Company MFG calm if
you need more convincing go check out
all of their videos over at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA
that's youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA ok so back to the analysis of poem
Anna fort and whether poem anna fort
will be pardoned by President Trump can
White analyzing this over at the New
York Times he says that the development
the Amana fort has been coordinating
with Trump is a blow to Robert Miller's
team because their questions to mr.
manna fort may be a road map to at least
part of their Special Counsel
investigation mr. Trump's lawyers can
now adjust their defense and the
president's responses and what they're
filing on Monday asserting mr. manna
forts dishonesty the prosecutors have
now lost him as a cooperating witness
it's a blow to mr. manna for will
receive no sentencing credit for his
brief cooperation but it also may be a
blow to president Trump why because it
turns out that the joint defense
agreement may not in fact hold here's
what Ken White says he says mr. man
afford like many of the hapless former
luminaries snared in mr. Mellors
investigation had a joint defense
agreement with mr. Trump such a pact
lets defense lawyers exchange
information without waiving
attorney-client privilege so Manta forts
lawyer could talk with Trump's lawyer
about what was going on and privilege
would not be waived and so the federal
government couldn't come in and say okay
what were you guys talking about what
were you coordinating about which is
very beneficial to team Trump obviously
under normal circumstances if a lawyer
reveals what a client said in confidence
or reveals strategy and analysis of a
case that information is no longer
confidential however and the government
can compel testimony about it a joint
defense agreement allows lawyers for
people with a common interest in a case
to share what they learn from clients
without that infinite information losing
its confidential nature joint defense
agreements are pretty common but the
pact almost always explicitly require
the parties to withdraw from the
agreement immediately if they cooperate
with the government in other words if
man affords team and from steam we're
coordinating before any of the the plea
agreement was arranged with manna fort
and then manna fort made the plea deal
than anything they said after the plea
deal is no longer confidential when
someone begins to cooperate says Ken
white his interests are no longer in
common with the other members of the
joint defense agreement by definition
they are now adverse this is often how
we learned that someone will soon plead
guilty the former national security
adviser Michael Flynn also had a defense
pact with the president but his
withdrawal from it Sigma
his cooperation and plea so maybe what
happened here is that Mister man affords
lawyers actually uncovered by doing this
they may have actually uncovered their
communications with team Trump and
offered material to Muller
so all of this is complicated all of its
complex suffice is suffice it to say
none of it is very good for president
Trump now President Trump is responding
to all of this with the ire they could
either demonstrate guilt or innocence
right he's he's saying that all of this
is a witch-hunt that there was no
collusion with the Russians and again I
tend to believe that there was no
collusion with the Russians of which
President Trump was aware because
President Trump does not have a greatly
functional brain to mouth filter and
that means that he says whatever comes
to mind he never said that he was
colluding with the Russians so I don't
think that he was I mean really it it it
almost is that simple because the
president is not particularly good at
hiding things but with that said is it
possible that collusion was going on at
a low level with Donald Trump jr. and
the Russians or with Paul Manafort in
the Russians that's a possibility as
well president Trump is responding to
all of this by saying listen enough is
enough enough is enough if we're
actually going to do this thing then I
will go after the Democrats if the
Democrats continue to push this forward
then I will then I will hit back as hard
as I possibly can
I'm just gonna declassify everything
that makes Democrats look bad here's
what President Trump had to say about it
he said he what he what he actually said
is in an interview with the New York
Post he said if they go down the
presidential harassment track if they
want to go and harass the president in
the administration I think that'd be the
best thing that would happen to me
I'm a counter-puncher and I will hit
them so hard they'd never been hit like
that he said I think it would help my
campaign if they want to play tough I
will do it they will see how devastating
these pages are meaning that the in VI
investigation was a set up by members of
the Obama administration to get him back
in 2016 there's no actual material this
is all basically just a hit job he says
that he could declassify FISA warrants
applications and other documents from
Robert Muller's probe he predicted the
disclose the disclosure would exposed
the FBI the Justice Department and the
Clinton campaign as being in cahoots to
set him up this would be the longtime
theory on the right the mother
investigation was launched under false
pretenses before was the mother
investigation right when it was just an
FBI investigation into Russian collusion
it was launched by people like Peter
struck
lissa page in an attempt to get Trump
because they didn't like Trump
personally and then this thing is just
spun out of control and that the Clinton
campaign had put together the seal
dossier which was used as the most solid
basis for attempting to go after
president Trump and his allies like
Carter page president Trump threatening
to declassify all that I've always asked
why he didn't declassified all of that
he basically said I didn't do it when I
didn't want to do it yet because I can
save it meaning that maybe he wants to
drop that as the responsive bombshell
right then instead of just declassifying
the stuff and undercutting the muller
investigation he wanted to wait until it
was most useful to him and then drop it
at that point which is an interesting
move I don't think that it's very good
for transparency but if President Trump
does have the material I think that it
would behoove him to drop it now as
opposed to later again using using
material that implicates the FBI DOJ and
Clinton campaign and corruption keeping
that under wraps as just a response
maybe politically smart but it's not
particularly good for the country
president Trump also responded by two
accusations that he is engaged in
obstruction of justice because the
president came out and you recall that
he has now gotten rid of Rod Rosenstein
over at the Department of Justice the
and he had retweeted a picture of a
bunch of of a bunch of Democrats and rod
Rosenstein showing his his Deputy
Attorney General there and they are all
behind bars
why was he showing his own Deputy
Attorney General behind bars well I
guess the reason he's showing his own
Deputy Attorney General behind bars is
because as he says he never should have
picked a special counsel so obviously
he's very angry about all of this he is
he's not happy about anything that is
happening
he said the Rosenstein belongs in jail
because he never should have picked a
special counsel I by the way I'm sorry
he's not actually fired rod Rosenstein
at this point he just sessions is gone
but Rosenstein is still there
in any case none of this translates well
for president Trump does any of this
actually spell Russian collusion that's
the bottom line to everybody the claim
that was made
our investigation and that they still
have to prove is that there was actual
collusion between team Trump and the
Russian government and that that
investigation is going to undercover
that collusion and that the president is
gonna be implicated in that collusion
it's now been nigh on two years or has
been two years since all of this began
we have yet to see any solid evidence
that that occurred we've seen hints
we've seen talk about Roger stone and
Jerome Corsi
we've seen a lot of dots we've seen a
lot of connections between those dots we
haven't seen clear testimony at this
point jumping to conclusions would be
wrong and while the left is overtly
excited about everything that is
currently happening right now I have my
doubts that this is going to result in
exactly what people on the left and in
the media hope it results in namely the
demise of President Trump I don't
actually think that that's what's going
to happen here I think that in the end
the Mullen report will come out it will
implicate some low-level people it will
implicate people like Michael Kohn it
may hit Paul Manafort but I don't think
it's gonna get all the way to the
President of the United States I think
Trump is probably safe here which is why
his best strategy is to not do much here
and simply let the investigation go
forward okay in just a second I want to
talk about media bias on another score
and an epidemic of anti-semitism that is
acceptable according to the left I'll
get to all of that in just one second
first let's talk about the amount of
stress that takes place upon your eyes
every day simply by the fact that you're
staring at screens like I stare at
screens all day long right I stare at my
computer screen or I stare at a
television screen or I'm staring at my
phone legitimately all day long and you
know what helps me with the stress on my
eyes Felix gray glasses they filter out
90% of high-energy blue light they
eliminate the glare coming off of all
the screen so I can live my life without
those tired dry eyes or blurry vision or
headaches usually it seems like a hassle
to protect your eyes which is why most
people don't do it you don't have to put
one of those crazy screens over your
computer screen that make it look all
dark Felix where glasses aren't like
those weird computer glasses that you've
seen before either right they're not
looking like those coke bottle glasses
from office space there's no yellow lens
tint and Felix square glasses are
handcrafted from premium Italian acetate
so they won't make you look nerdy which
by the way would be a massive
improvement for me
in fact throwing on some Felix greys is
an easy way to look pretty put together
Felix gray glasses are available in non
prescription prescription
readers makes me look sophisticated when
I just feel like looking more
intelligence I throw in my Felix square
glasses and walk around the office don't
go another day looking at screens
without the help of some Felix Grey's go
to Felix gray glasses dot-com slash men
to protect those eyes today that's Felix
gray glasses calm slash man go check it
out honestly like avoid the headaches
Felix gray glasses calm slash menus that
slash man so they know that we sent you
okay so I have to say that in the past
few weeks really since the pittsburgh
shooting the left has been on a tear
about the supposed anti-semitism of the
trump administration we saw a piece from
the New York Times saying the Jordan
Ivanka were complicit in anti-semitism
we saw many pieces talking about how the
Trump administration had forwarded
anti-semitism rises in hate crimes
against Jews and all the rest first of
all the statistics that were cited by
the ADL were just not true but beyond
that if you want to talk about real
mainstream anti-semitism it does not
exist in the Trump administration it
exists on the left and this is coming
from a guy who received an enormous
amount of anti-semitism in 2016 like the
most of anyone on the Internet in 2016
from the alt-right from people who I
thought Trump was winking and nodding at
during 2016 but to suggest the Trump
administration has been complicit in
anti-semitism is just bizarre it's a
bizarre claim there's no evidence of it
whatsoever the Trump administration not
the Trump campaign the Trump
administration that is a bizarre weird
an unsupportable claim the mainstream
left however is daily involved in
anti-semitism and it is amazing to watch
as the left it defends its own from open
anti-semitism the latest example comes
courtesy of guy named Mark Lamont Hill
mark Lamont Hill is considered an
intelligent political commentator over
at CNN and he was speaking at the UN
yesterday and he called for the
elimination of the State of Israel he
used the language of Hamas here's what
Mark Lamont Hill had to say must
advocate and promote non-violence
at every opportunity but we cannot
endorse a narrow politics of
respectability that shames Palestinians
for resisting for refusing to do nothing
in the face of state violence and ethnic
cleansing to commit to political action
that will give us what justice requires
and that is a free Palestine okay a free
pass and then he and then he went on and
he said that the free Palestine must be
from the
River to the sea which is the which is
the 1488 statement so the 1488 statement
and in Nazi terminology it's meant to be
eighty-eight is supposed to be the
eighth letter of the alphabet twice Oh
Heil Hitler
the fourteen words something like we
pledge to protect and keep the white
race or some such nonsense
they 1488 statement is sort of the credo
of Nazis okay these the credo of radical
Muslim Nazis okay
the credo of these folks is Palestine
shall be free from the river to the sea
this is a thing that gets chanted at
every terrorist rally the idea being
that Palestine from the emergency
meaning Jordan River to the
Mediterranean Sea will be entirely Yudin
right right the idea here will be the
Palestine will exist Israel will no
longer exist Palestine will replace
Israel and that inherently means the
destruction of the Jews and the genocide
of the Jews okay this is not they've not
been hiding the ball on this it is not
as though any of this is a giant secret
none of this is a giant secret okay and
Mark Lamont Hill has a long history of
such anti-semitic comments in May 2018
he'll implied that Israelis were
murderers in the Huffington Post
according to Hank berry and over at the
Daily wire he says this is about the
seven years struggle of a people who
have been expelled murdered robbed in
prisons and occupied he defended
Palestinians right to use violence
against Israel and then said the
Palestinians actually wanted peace which
is nonsense he then continued by
slamming Israel's right to exist he said
by naturalizing the idea that nation
states have a right to exist we
undermine our ability to offer a moral
critique of Israel or any settler
colonies origin story Israel is not a
settler colony Israel is the eternal
homeland of the Jewish people the only
reason anyone cares about it ever
historically is because the Jews were
there first
it is biblically promised and not only
that there has been a continuous
presence in the Land of Israel by Jews
since anyone gave a damn about the land
mark Lamont Hill is also a guy who has
shied who's basically fluffed off and
openly antes meta commentary from Louis
Farrakhan Marc Lamont Hill said that it
was offensive to compare Palestinian
resistance to settler colonialism to the
actions of Isis even while Hamas was
firing rockets at Jewish areas and in
2014 he tweeted that he opposed the
occupation of Gaza the only problem
being that there was no occupation of
Gaza Israel left Gaza in August
2005 in 2008 Sean Hannity confronted
mark Lamont Hill with the remarks of
Louis Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan had
called Judy's Megara religion Marc
Lamont Hill was tight with Louis
Farrakhan and here is what Hill said he
said quote I do not know whether
Farrakhan is an anti-semite those quotes
are severely out of context
okay so Marc Lamont Hill has been a
longtime anti-semite there's there's not
really a lot of question about this his
statement here is an open embrace of
anti-semitism so what have you seen from
left nothing dead it's silent nothing
not a thing so we get a lot about Steve
King we get a lot about President Trump
we get a lot about the alt-right and we
hear a lot about anti-semitism on the
right even though the amount of
anti-semitism on the right is
significantly lower than the amount of
anti-semitism on the left but Marc
Lamont Hill goes out there and says from
the river to the sea Palestine shall be
free calling for the full-scale genocide
of seven million Jews and everybody's
like that whatever whatever is you CNN
commentator so what and this this does
have an interesting relationship with
the left view of anti-semitism generally
so in this context I bring up Alexandra
Ocasio Cortes now every time I bring up
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez I do so with
this proviso the reason I'm talking
about Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is because
she has been appointed by the media and
many on the left as a thought leader for
the Democratic Party
I'm not picking it's not like I just
pick random Congress people out of a hat
it's not like I'm just there for 35 of
them it's not like I'm just like you
know what let's talk about some weirdo
from like from Kansas today
hey Alexandra Ocasio Cortez was a
national figure she was made a national
figure in the face of the party by the
media when the face of your party is
associating with open anti-semites like
Linda Sarsour when the face of your
party has embraced everyone associated
with the boycott divest sanctions
movement which is anti-semitism the idea
that people should not buy products from
Israel and every product from Israel
should be labeled basically with a
Jewish star so people cannot buy hey
Alexandra but then
Alexandra o cosmic when she does all
this right she'd supported the Iran deal
she is a routine basher of Israel and
she she spent a long time bashing Israel
gets to her past comments in a second
she has said that she is not in favor of
a two-state solution
she told Haaretz which is the anti
Israel Israeli newspaper she told her
our 'its
back in this would have been July that
she didn't know whether she was in favor
of the two
solution she said maybe there should be
a one-state solution which means the
abolition of the State of Israel right
she said all of this clearly and then
she tweets out stuff like this this is a
picture of NBC from NBC News of that
migrant family running away from tear
gas she's asking to be considered a
refugee and applying for status isn't a
crime it wasn't for Jewish families
fleeing Germany it wasn't for targeted
families fleeing Rwanda it wasn't for
Communities fleeing war-torn Syria it
isn't for those fleeing violence in
Central America
comparing migrants at the southern
border to Jewish victims of the
Holocaust is not only disgusting it's
insulting historically intellectually on
every level but it does speak to
something deeper and this is something I
want to get into in just one second
something deep and important about how
the Left views anti-semitism now I'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about making your face look
better I mean you wake up every morning
and look in the mirror and go ah well
you shouldn't have to do that hey it's
that saggy draw a line that draw line
double chin that's what gives your age
way well you don't have to do that
introducing the brand new genja cell jaw
line treatment with dual peptide and MDL
technology Germany's most advanced
technology ever it not only tightens
that saggy draw on it plumps the
lipophilic layers of your skin to
contour and define the jaw line within
minutes you use peptides and metal
lactones together for the first time it
works amazingly quickly the results get
better every day no one else has this
technology or their proprietary chemical
free base so say goodbye to that double
chin minimize that double chin right now
and here is the good news it is yours
free when you order Gen you sell for the
under eye bags and puffiness as well I
know that this product is great because
my mom uses it it comes to our house
originally him for my wife my mom
grabbed it she started using it and now
every time it shows up at the house my
mom steals it thanks mom for results in
12 hours Jenny sells immediate effects
is also free texts chin two seven seven
four or five three or go to Gen you sell
calm for this introductory offer imagine
that double chin going away in about a
week with that draw line treatment and
here's the thing it's a hundred percent
guaranteed or you get your money back so
if you don't like what you're seeing
well you get your money back so what are
you risking exactly Tex chin she's seven
seven four five three or go to Gen you
sell calm one more time chin text it to
seven seven four five three or go to Gen
you sell calm go check it out right now
okay I want to get to why the left
complete
blows it on anti-semitism and a deeper
form of anti-semitism in which the left
is engaged which is really messed up
I'll talk about that plus a new study
about how the Left treats black folks in
the United States which is pretty
fascinating and I think worthy of
discussion and I have to tell you this
story of how a pedophile basically
escaped prosecution because he happened
to be rich and had famous friends we'll
get to all of that but you're gonna have
to go over to daily wired.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month get the rest
of this show free get the rest of the
under Clavin show get the rest of get
the rest of Michael Noel's his show
when I say free I mean for $9.99 a month
you got all of those things behind the
paywall and you also get access to our
Sunday special we have a bunch of
fantastic Sunday specials coming up I'm
very excited it's a lot of religion talk
just before Christmas but it's religion
and politics so much good stuff over
there we have so much brand-new matter I
can't even I can't explain to you so how
much great stuff you are going to get
when you go behind the paywall I will
say to you that with ninety nine dollars
a year instead of $9.99 a month you get
this the leftist Sears hot or cold
tumblr now I've been making the Clement
this is keeping me free from disease so
far so good I will keep making that
claim until I actually am diseased at
which point I will claim it had nothing
to do with the tumblr so full disclosure
it is a great tumblr okay it keeps your
hot drinks hot it keeps your cold drinks
cold how does it know go check it out
right now for 99 dollars a year it's
pretty spectacular also make sure that
you check us out at YouTube iTunes
please leave us reviewed iTunes it
always helps our ranking over there we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk about what this
actually means in terms of anti-semitism
on the left so mark Lamont Hill makes
openly anti-semitic statements okay
there's not he's pretending it's not
anti-semitic to say from the river to
the sea Palestine shall be free which
means Israel no longer exists and Israel
as a Jewish state no longer exists and
I'd like for him to name a Muslim
dominated country where the Jews are
treated fantastic and where the Jews
exist
how many quick quiz what percentage of
Israel's population is Arab or Muslim
answer about 20% quick quiz
what percentage of the Palas taya of the
Palestinian Authority or Hamas
population is Jewish answer zero zero
zero Jews live in those areas and yet we
are supposed to believe that these are
morally equivalent entities it's just
insane and not only that mark Lamont
Hill wants the latter entity to take
over for the former entity fantastic but
what you see from the left are open
engagements with anti-semites like Louis
Farrakhan like Linda Sarsour like illa
Hana Omar like Rasheeda Talib both of
the latter two of whom are elected
members of Congress like keith Ellison
who is now Attorney General of the state
of Minnesota and was the deputy DNC head
and all of these people in positions of
prominence anti-semites all involved in
anti-semitic activity and rhetoric no
problem but then you will see the exact
same people using the Holocaust as a
club on ancillary issues and here's
what's happening basically a lot of
folks on the Left have decided that
anti-semitism is only important when it
is not applied to the Jews
so anti-semitism is good to use as a
model right you can talk about the
Holocaust but only in the context of
talking about people who are the new
Jews right the Jews themselves they're
not victims the Jews are very powerful
the Jews are behind world events the
Jews themselves are very rich and well
educated but what we can learn from
history is that people can be victimized
and those people now would be the new
Jews so the migrants according to
Alexandra Ocasio Cortes are the new Jews
the Jews in Israel not the new Jews
right not true at all
right in terms of anti-semitism they're
not victims of circumstance the left
says anti-semitism is about victimhood
victimhood does not apply to the Jews it
applies to the new Jews there's been a
sort of rub
placement theology in anti-semitism on
the left in which the Jews have been
removed from the question of
anti-semitism and this allows folks on
the left to engage in open anti-jewish
behavior open anti-semitism while
simultaneously using anti-semitism as an
excuse for pushing policy with regard to
other groups now you would never see
this this is this in and of itself is a
form of anti-semitism the reason I say
that is that you would never see this
with regard to any other group okay you
don't see it you don't see anybody say
you know what you know black slavery
black slavery the black folks in America
they're just fine like let's not talk
about black folks in America anymore
the real slaves the real black slaves in
America today our X group if you said
that you would be accused of making
light of slavery and properly so but
instead what we've got on the left is we
can use the Holocaust and use it as the
basis of arguing about migration
patterns on our southern border but we
can simultaneously pretend that Hamas is
fine and that Israel should be boycotted
in and divested from if you're making
anti-semitism a political tool on behalf
of a non-jewish disfavored group and
you're ignoring your own treatment of
the Jews I would suggest that you are
making light of anti-semitism and in
fact engaging in a soft form of it in
Mark Lamont Hills case not even a soft
form a very hard form of anti-semitism
okay
speaking of intersectionality and race I
do have to point out today that when it
comes to leftist hypocrisy on racism
there is really no limit jay-z who has
been hosted at the White House right
it's a great American political figure
you know this really was really bad when
Kanye West went to the White House when
jay-z went there with Obama like every
five minutes that was totally cool jay-z
he has a he made a statement today he is
in a case with the American Arbitration
Association they are judging a trademark
case and here is what he said he said
the triple A's lack the American
Arbitration Association is lack of
african-american arbitrators came as a
surprise in part because triple A's
advertising tout its diversity he says
that the panel from the American
Arbitration Association is too white to
be fair and what is to this case is
basically jay-z filed a case against the
clothing company Iconix to delay an
impending arbitration over his trade
trademark infringement claims related to
a line of rock nation baseball caps
ikonics bought jay-z's apparel brown in
2007 and then ikonics sued the mogul in
Manhattan federal court last year
claiming that a hat deal with Major
League Baseball interfered with their
licensing agreement jay-z said he was
confronted with the stark reality when
he reviewed members of the American
Arbitration Association he could not
identify a single African American
arbitrator on the large and complex
cases roster composed of hundreds of
arbitrators that had the background and
experience to preside over the situation
the Association eventually identified
three black arbitrators but one of them
couldn't serve due to a conflict of
interest
jay-z argues minority business owners
should be able to select from a group
that reflects the diverse population I'm
old enough to recall when President
Donald Trump then a candidate Donald
Trump said that a judge of Mexican
heritage could not adjudicate properly
his Trump University case in California
because he had a particular immigration
program and the quote-unquote Mexican
judge we biased against him this was
called racism it is also called racism
when jay-z says I cannot have anyone but
a black person to arbitrate my case it's
plain simple racism but if you're on the
Left that's where the racism is just
fine
so racism in which a member of the black
community says only black people can
judge me that's cool anti-semitism in
which we talk about the elimination of
Israel while at the same time using the
Holocaust to promote immigration policy
on our southern border that's totally
fine according to the left and the white
left just goes along with this why they
go along with this because the white
left panders and they don't just
Pandaren terms of their policy they've
Hana in terms of in terms of their
language this is a fascinating new study
it's a it's a study from Yale insights
it reports that Sidney Dupree assistant
professor of organizational behavior at
Yale School of Management and her
co-author Susan Fiske of Princeton
University they wanted to know how
White's interacted with minorities to
pre stated there's less work that
explores how well-intentioned whites
tried to get along with racial
minorities we wanted to know their
strategies for increasing connections
between members of different social
groups and how effective these
strategies are well tell you the
punchline of the study in just one
second so here's what happened the
researchers examined the words used in
74 different campaign speeches delivered
by Democrats and Republicans over a 25
year period around half the speeches
were delivered to a mostly minority
audience
those features were then compared to
speeches delivered to a mostly white
audience to elements of the speech were
analyzed words related to competence and
words related to warmth here's what the
results showed the results showed that
Democratic candidates used fewer
competence related words speaking to
minorities than when speaking to white
audiences Republican candidates did not
change their discourse in other words
Democrats pander to minority audiences
by refusing to talk about the same
topics in the same way that they would
talk to white audiences they are
racially discriminating against black
people they are maybe you think it's a
beneficial discrimination but it is
certainly a discrimination when you say
something in front of a black audience
you would never say in front of a white
audience and vice versa
Duprey said it was really surprising to
see that for nearly three decades
Democratic presidential candidates have
been engaging in this predicted behavior
the researchers then tested white
participants to see how they would
interact with a hypothetical or presumed
real interaction partner half the time
the partner was given a name that
ostensibly sounded white like Emily the
rest of the time the partner eceived a
name that sounded ostensibly non-white
like Lakeisha participants chose a list
of words all of which have been rated
for warmth or competence to use to send
an email to the partner the researchers
found that leftist shoed using words
that would lie that would lymon them as
highly competent when addressing
minorities conservatives simply talked
the way they always did according to the
pre it was kind of an unpleasant
surprise to see the subtle but
persistent effect even if it's
ultimately well-intentioned it could be
seen as patronizing seen as patronizing
it is patronizing if you are using words
that you would never use with white
people with black people because you
think that you have to pander to black
people in some way this would be
intersectional discrimination but the
left's okay with that because if you
have to pander to certain members of the
intersectional paradigm in order to
achieve your political goals that's
exactly what you ought to do the Jews
are less important to this goal and
they're taken for granted apparently
black audience is not so much by white
liberals who are attempting to reach out
to black audiences pretty astonishing
stuff and then you hear folks on the
Left say that President Trump is
undermining the unity of the country
President Trump is undermining the unity
listen I have no illusions the President
Trump is a great unifier I don't think
that he is I think President Trump can
do better on that score but to suggest
that the left is a great unifying body
in America
is a lie president Trump is a
reactionary for US president Trump and
the current Republican administration
are a direct reaction to the
polarization of politics around racial
and identity politics for eight years
under Barack Obama and longer under the
Democratic Party more generally I know
Chris Matthews rme's a say saying that
President Trump thing about ACTA it's
like Zimbabwe over here neglecting the
fact that Zimbabwe is a case in point in
which the leadership of Zimbabwe h-her a
tyranny forcibly discriminated against
white farmers it's pretty amazing stuff
here
Chris Matt got a shake up in the morning
oh really show right in here I'll
rumpled looking at garbage and you start
talking oh you know I'm I don't know
what the mob way is I do not pronounce
it one time I said Zimbabwe I didn't no
no no go I was reading about Zimbabwe
today and I'd been to the zip wire I
know it's a young country with all kinds
of problems but that was that sort of a
young democracy trying to figure things
out he is taking us back to where they
are where all the opposition does is say
that people win elections are crooked
that everything's rigged
everything's nothing's on the on the
level there's no such thing as objective
truth everything is tribal I swear this
is insane this is insane
they're saying the president Trump is
the one who started tribalism he's the
one Barack Obama said about Trayvon
Martin if I had a son he would have
looked like Trayvon Martin without even
bothering to examine the facts of the
case President President Obama went out
there in the middle of the Ferguson
riots and said that the community of
Ferguson wouldn't make something up like
Michael Brown except that it was made up
about Michael Brown it's it's just it's
maddening and then you wonder why
there's a reactionary tribalism on the
other side
hey tribalism in all of its forms is
garbage okay the sort of tribal politics
is yucky your identity group politics is
gross but let's not pretend that the
left is not the initiator of it because
the left is the initiator of it and it's
pretty obvious the left has initiated
all this sort of stuff yuck yuck yuck
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like my wife and I have delved
into another series this is the series
bodyguard on Netflix starring the guy
who plays raba from Game of Thrones
who it turns out is actually a really
good actor so he's good in Game of
Thrones and he plays a completely
different character in this it's
compelling
well shot it's it's interestingly
written I have no idea where it's going
specifically them but you can check it
check out bodyguard on Netflix really
good here a little bit of a preview
David I'm signing you to the Home
Secretary very good moment to move up a
meeting she's got an agenda to heighten
fear and to seize power that doesn't
require apologizing for the past did you
mean what you said I don't need you to
protect me rest assured love I'll do as
required
it's okay it's okay it's really good
okay so this series is well worth
watching well shot interesting also it
turns out that you're allowed to make a
TV show with radical Muslims who commit
terrorist acts who knew who knew you
were allowed to make such TV shows but
it turns out that you actually are now I
don't know where this series is going
all I can say is that it does it
actually take that threat somewhat
seriously which is something I haven't
seen on TV too often really since I
guess in in the jack ryan series they do
it a little bit and really since before
that maybe 24 you'd have to go all the
way back to 24 early seasons before they
were told they're not allowed to have
radical Muslim terrorists be bad guys
okay time for a bevy of things that I
hate so many hateful things today okay
thing that I hate number one so number
one there is a there's a video of me
talking about global warming that's
going around and I just want to correct
the record because people are such
stupid idiots so the the the video of me
is talking about the fact that human
migration has always reflected climate
change meaning that people move to
places that are not underwater for
example like there are places now cities
that are underwater
who lives there the answer no one oh
yeah you know why because you can't live
underwater you can't breathe underwater
so in any case there's a speech that I
was giving when I was talking about you
know what will happen if the water level
rises on the coast people will move they
will sell and they will move and feel
like well they can't sell their houses
if they're underwater it's like oh god
you people are so stupid that's not what
I'm saying at all
what I'm saying is
if you forecast that in 20 years your
place is going to be under water you're
going to sell it right now at the
earliest available opportunity I don't
see Barbra Streisand's selling her
beachfront property in Malibu okay I
don't see any of these folks in Miami
who are complaining about global warming
selling their property if they really
thought this was a grave threat
wouldn't they be selling right now and
by the way if you aren't if there's no
market if you can't sell the property
cuz everybody knows it's going to be
underwater then you know you don't sell
and you move the point that I was making
there is not that you're not gonna lose
money if you live on a beachfront
property in the water level rise of
course gonna lose money what I'm saying
is you're not gonna die because if it's
rising 3 inches a year you're not just
gonna sit there in your living room for
like 50 years
waiting for the water level to reach our
nose that's what I'm saying people don't
stay where there is a slow creeping
knowledge that they are going to die
because that's stupid and if they think
that's going to happen over the next 50
years they're going to sell and move
inland that was the point that I was
making so well done left great gotcha
just one point out how dumb that is okay
a couple of other things that are
incredibly dumb so the Huffington Post
making everything garbage they've
they've now cut a video saying that
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer is bad
because everything is bad all the things
are bad there are no good things now
suffice it to say I'm not a devotee of
the Santa right Santa never sat in his
lap never got you never came down my
chimney when no he'd get his fat butt
down there anyway have no clue yeah I'd
be frankly if something if some random
dude showed up in my house and was
sticking gifts under the tree get shot I
mean that's just--that's I'm not I'm not
a fan of strangers entering my premises
but in any case Rudolph the red-nose
Ranger is a charming little stop action
cartoon it's it's it's charming and it's
lovely and there's nothing wrong with it
but it is problematic according to The
Huffington Post why is it problematic
it is heteronormative cisgender and
racist huh well yes
no really this is raggedy what what I'm
sick huh okay so here is here is
huffington post trying to explain why
you should never let your children watch
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer instead
you should let them watch the Macy's
Thanksgiving Parade where two women make
out
Rudolph the red-nose Ranger is a holiday
classic says The Huffington Post that
returns to TV each holiday season but
lately viewers are noticing the tale may
not be so jolly after all huh
farmer fans are pointing out Rudolph's
father verbally abuses him Santa Claus
parades downer for his son's nose the
school the school coach encourages
bullying Donner forbids his wife from
joining the search for their son
Clarence at Clarice's dad is a bigot
even the elf is an outcast from wanting
to be a dentist okay let me point out a
couple of things the entire narrative of
Rudolph is that he's mistreated for 95%
of the story that's literally the story
this is like honest honest to god this
is like the story of the ugly duckling
like you know what we just found out the
story of the ugly duckling is
problematic cuz the swans treat the duck
badly like yeah that's the story and
that what now
but yes everything is bad so I love this
it's gonna ruin your child's in a sense
if they watch a fictional reindeer be
mistreated because of his glowing nose
only to emerge triumphant in the end
your child will not be damaged if you
put them on puberty blockers at age six
yeah I'm gonna trust you guys with my
kids makes perfect sense to me okay
speaking of people who should not trust
with your kids another thing that I hate
today so there's a story from ABC about
how as some people at Southwest were
making fun of a five-year-old why were
they making fun of the five-year-old
because she has a weird name here's the
mom talking about it the gate agent
started mocking my child's name laughing
pointing at me and my daughter and
talking to other employees so I turned
around and just said like hey I can hear
you so if I can hear you my daughter can
- like I'd appreciate it you just stop
okay um it turns out that the reason
that everybody is going to the the
reason that her daughter was being
mocked is because she named her daughter
I kid you not AB City spelled ABCDE now
you shouldn't Mock the five-year-old son
five-year-olds fault but there are idiot
parent named them you should mock the
mother and the mother is well worthy of
mockery please parents do not name your
kids something that is just going to get
the mocked
your kids have people they have lives
please don't do that right name your kid
something that has meaning you know like
I'm just glad that she didn't pick like
V W X Y Z Reilly then then then her
kid's name would have been wix's which
would have been really awkward and that
woulda knocked the kid but I'd mocked
the mom who has the brains of a kumquat
apparently visit parents you have a
responsibility your children and just
because you wanted to name your kid
after the alphabet I mean is her name
alphabet e maybe that that'd be kind of
great if her name was alphabet e any
case it's yeah bad parenting at work
right there okay other things that I
hate today
so there's a video that's now making the
rounds if Jesus is a if Jesus was
Republican if Jesus was a Republican so
this is coming from now this which is
the repository for many things stupid I
can't say all things stupid because I've
already reserved box for that although
technically in Fox's the repository of
all things stupid there wouldn't be any
stupid leftover for now this so I have
to revise my statement in fact they're
both repositories for many stupid things
here is now this which is promoting a
video in which Jesus is a Republican but
of course it's a bunch of people who
have done a cursory read of the old and
new Testament if they've done that and
then they basically misinterpret
radically what Jesus was saying and then
they say that Jesus is actually a social
justice Democrat in favor of
transgenderism abortion and gay rights
so here is a little bit of this comedic
video allegedly comedic see I say unto
you whoever welcomes one of these little
ones in my name might be letting in a
murderer
or a drug let's get her to a detention
center you know so we can figure out
what's going on
this comedy sketch masked what would
Jesus do if you're a Republican and you
gave me something to eat I was thirsty
and you gave me something to drink and
behold now I'm all lazy and entitled you
shouldn't have done that do unto others
as you suspect they might want to do
unto you what is a man profited if he
gain the whole world but lose his soul a
lot he is profited a lot okay like it
you don't understand conservatism you
don't understand republicanism and you
don't understand anything about the
Bible like a thing about the Bible Jesus
never says illegal immigration is
mandated by the Bible that's absurd
that's absurd in fact Jesus family was
on the way to register Jesus's birth we
got a lot of New Testament scholar but
that's what they were doing when he was
born in Bethlehem
hey and as far as this idea that do unto
others as they would have them do unto
you that that is somehow do unto others
as you think they're going to do unto
you
nothing nothing in Christianity says you
have to allow other people to murder you
or endanger your kids obviously the idea
that the Republicans are anti charity
I'd like to see this guy's tax returns
okay on a per capita basis religious
people in the United States give far
more charity than anyone else and people
who are Republican give far more charity
than people who are Democrats not close
red states per capita much more
charitable than blue states per capita
but again
this is this laziness reading of the
Bible by people who don't care about the
Bible at all I got okay I want to see
your video on what you what Jesus
actually had to say about you know the
sanctity of human life or or marriage
and real controversial there what Jesus
had to say about marriage you know
woman's submitting to their husbands and
all that real dicey stuff for like I
love that one they selectively quote
Jesus at people it's like come on come
on yeah it is what it's like when people
selectively quote the Old Testament at
me I'm okay you wanted the original
Hebrew you want the surrounding so Kim
like boy what do you want here and I'm
not even a great expert I'm just like a
normal Orthodox Jews what we do like on
a daily basis
yeah idiots okay time for one more thing
that I hate and then we will get out of
here so this is a horrifying story so it
turns out that there's guy named Jeffrey
Epstein you may remember Jeffrey Epstein
Jeffrey Epstein
as you'll recall is a was a pedophile
okay and this this pedophile was deeply
connected with a multiplicity of major
characters including Bill Clinton and
Donald Trump according to the Miami
Herald Jeffrey Epstein had a little
black book filled with the names and
personal phone numbers of some of the
world's wealthiest and most influential
people from Bill Clinton and Donald
Trump to actors actresses scientists and
business tycoons a money manager for the
super-rich Epstein had two private jets
the largest single residence in
Manhattan an island in the Caribbean a
ranch in New Mexico and a waterfront
estate in Florida but Epstein also had
an obsession for years Epstein lured an
endless stream of teenage girls to his
Palm Beach mansion offering to pay for
the member for massages instead police
say for years he coerced middle and
high-school girls into engaging in sex
acts with him and others as evidence
emerged that there were victims and
witnesses outside of Palm Beach the FBI
began an investigation in 2006 and to
whether Epstein and others employed by
him were involved in underage sex
trafficking but in 2007 despite
substantial evidence that corroborated
the girls stories of abuse by Epstein
the US attorney in Miami Alexander
Acosta signed off on a secret deal for
the multi-millionaire one that ensured
he would never spend a day in prison
Acosta is now president Trump's
Secretary of Labor he agreed to seal the
agreement so that no one not even
Epstein's victims would know the full
extent of his crimes or who was involved
it so basically what happened is that
Epstein was able to get off on a minor
charge for legitimately hundreds of
cases of child molestation because he
apparently had deep connections to a
variety of highfalutin characters
Epstein was basically a career Democrat
the prosecutor in this case is a
Republican all this goes to show is that
there is truth to the idea that if you
have friends in the right places
America's criminal justice system can be
a serious serious problem that there is
the ability for prosecutors to let you
off on crimes you never should've been
let off on and what's worse is that we
still don't know who's out there because
the agreement was sealed we don't know
who else was implicated we don't know
which friends and associates were
implicated in all of this and this is
this is ugly ugly stuff if you look at
his inner circle you're looking at you
know you are looking at big Ninja
his associates you're looking at people
ranging from Bill Clinton to Donald
Trump to Alan Dershowitz to there's just
a variety of people who are now where
all of these people implicated in his
sex abuse know but we don't know who was
implicated and we don't know how many
victims there were because of this
perversion of justice this is you wanna
talk about a meet you problem this is a
me-too problem you're and it spans the
political aisle we're gonna talk about a
me-too problem
how about les Moonves over at CBS who
apparently had a plan to bury a sexual
assault allegation and it's reported by
the New York Times today powerful people
have been getting away with bad crimes
for a very very long time in this
country and in every other country as
well it is why the Bible says that you
should treat the poor and the rich
equally under justice and under the law
and it's why we have to have a justice
system that is answerable for everybody
this epstein case is just an example of
how that is not true just a shocking
shocking story ok we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing